[Music]
parliament set its position on a series
of climate laws designed to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 55
by 2030 including better use of land for
carbon storage other proposals were sent
back to committee for further
deliberation
meps called for a convention with a view
to treaty change under article 48 of the
treaty on the eu this came after the
conference on the future of europe
demanded institutional reform including
an end to veto powers in the council
a hundred and five days after russia
invaded ukraine ruslan stefanczuk the
speaker of the vokov narada addressed
the european parliament he thanked meps
for their support and said ukraine
deserved eu candidate status
cuovardis ida is the winner of the 2022
lux audience award
the film recounts the 1995 genocide of
more than 8 000 bosnian muslims during
the war in the former yugoslavia
35 years ago turkey applied to join the
eu talks have been stalled since 2018.
mep's warned ankara must improve its
human rights record and uphold eu values
if accession discussions are to resume
[Music]